[shouting]
[hip-hop music playing]
♪ ♪
- Afternoon, all.
Would you mind mellowing
your tunes?
All of the reclaimed
driftwood inside
really amplifies the sound.
We just want everyone to have
a pleasant dining experience.
Now, who wants a free sample
of vegan--
- We ain't turning down shit.
This our city.
all: Yeah!
[cheering]
[siren chirps]
- This is an unlawful gathering.
I'm ordering you to turn down
the music and disperse,
or we'll be forced to--
- Aye, we ain't
turning down shit.
You can't silence us.
- I can do whatever I want.
Now I said turn it down.
- Oh, yeah?
Make us.
- Oh, sweet Jesus!
[thunderous stomping]
- Get your gentrified dick
back here.
♪ ♪
- I said get back.
And for the love of Christ, turn
that oogidy boogidy music off.
♪ ♪
- [choking]
Oops.
- Oh, shit, not again.
- Oh, God, they killed
Mr. Proper's...radio.
- Well, guess the riot's over.
I watch BET.
You people don't do anything
without music.
- Like hell we don't!
Let's take back our community
by destroying it.
[cheering]
- What should we do?
- We got this, so throw it.
- No, you throw it.
- I ain't gonna lie.
It's weird without music.
- Gimme that!
- And what you think you gonna
do with that, mother[bleep]?
- [grunts]
[creaking]
I've seen this before.
Everybody get down!
- I'm Don Lemon.
We're here on the ground
in Chamberlain Heights,
where events are quickly
spiraling out of control.
Obviously, once again,
there's a smell of marijuana
in the air.
- Man, so I'm smoking
a little dojha.
Mind your business, nigga.
I've had a rough day.
- Some people would say
that rioting
only hurts communities
that are already suffering.
Might it not be more effective
to express your discontent
through the ballot box?
- Man, everybody knows
that don't make no difference.
In the hood,
only one box matters.
- Um, what's that, brother?
- Hot box, nigga!
[blows]
- [coughing]
That tastes like the chronic.
- Yeah, Donny Don, now that's
what I call a Lemon Party.
[hip-hop music]
♪ ♪
[alternative rock music]
- Do I hear a slow jam?
- Who play this type of music
at a riot?
♪ ♪
- Play "Neighborhood
Number Three."
- Eat shit.
Play "Suburbs."
- Damn, white folks done
gentrified the riot.
- It reminds me of Burning Man,
but before it got all corporate.
- It look like we
too late, my nigs.
- [gasps]
I really don't like
what's happening
to our neighborhood.
- Ugh, I'm over this place.
- Yeah, our work here is done.
[phone ringing]
Hey, there's a new neighborhood
popping up,
and it's real shitty.
- Sounds great.
Let's go.
[train whistle toots]
all: Yeah!
- Whoo, whoo, whoo!
- Yeah, baby.
- Yeah!
Ah!
- Gimme that short dick.